we're in a new golden age of television
not to mention a golden age of
unexpected TV deaths with a dramatic
uptick and the quality of TV shows came
a commitment to keeping audiences
guessing with as many surprises as
possible that means almost no character
is safe
here are some deaths from the first half
of 2016 that threw us for a loop it
should go without saying but spoilers
ahead
Ziva Devine NCIS former Mossad officer
and NCIS agent Ziva Devine portrayed by
cote de pablo was one of the most
beloved characters on the most watched
drama on TV and when the Pablo left the
show to pursue new roles in 2014 her
character's story was wrapped up with a
nice send-off so there really wasn't
much need for Ziva to ever be mentioned
on NCIS again and why it felt
particularly cruel that it was announced
that her character it died off screen in
a missile attack on her family home
man's gotta call
CIFA Denise the walking dad emmy-winner
Merritt Wever had a really nice art
going as Denise in the walking dead
she took over his town doctor in
Alexandria after her predecessors
untimely demise she entered into a
romantic relationship with Terra despite
a fear of commitment and she even
survived a hostage situation she
outlined her reasons for diving into
love with an impassioned monologue on a
supply run with Daryl and Rosita
explaining that she finally felt ready
to stand up and fight for her life only
to be cut off by an arrow through her
eye and brain shot from the woods by a
lurking Dwight makes me sick that you
guys aren't even trying because you're
strong and you're smart and you're both
really good people and if you don't wait
and face yer Robin Hood once upon a time
the long-running ABC show that is deftly
thrown together fairytale icons
mythological characters and Disney
favorites only got darker and more
complicated in its fifth season
especially for Robin Hood who just could
never catch a break first he found out
his beloved Maid Marian was actually
Zelena the Wicked Witch of the West and
then Hades threatened the life of his
other true love Regina forcing Robin to
sacrifice himself to save her ladies
first
Ramsay Bolton Game of Thrones murder
sadist and serial rapist Ramsay Bolton
was arguably the most evil character in
the entire run of Game of Thrones which
is saying something on the show that
gave us Joffrey Baratheon and since bad
people thrive on Game of Thrones we
expected him to outlive everyone but
after Ramsay go to Jon Snow into war
their conflict erupted into the bloody
Battle of the bastards finally
face-to-face with John Ramsay tried to
avoid a physical fight by firing arrows
at him only to be tackled beaten bloody
and tossed into a dungeon where he
suffered the final indignity of being
eaten alive by his own dogs on the order
of the wife he wants gleefully tortured
Hodor
Game of Thrones fans finally learned how
brand Starks protector Hodor got his
name Mughal poodle but it came in one of
the most heartbreaking plot twists in
the show's history turns out his name
was really Willis but in a time travel
mishap Brandon advertently showed Willis
a vision of his own death while serving
as a human barricade against a horde of
zombies the poor kid collapsed screaming
hold the door while in present-day Hodor
made the ultimate sacrifice we're really
gonna miss you big guy thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which character deaths
shocked you the most this year